30 mars dernier en région parisienne
c'est un jour un peu particulier pour
axel il fait sa première rentrée des
classes à polytechnique l'école est
située à saclay à 25 km au sud de paris
[Musique]
le campus s'étend sur 160 hectares
une véritable petite ville où vivent un
millier d'étudiants et une cinquantaine
de militaires on trouve presque tout sur
place une épicerie
[Musique]
un bar des terrains de sport et bien sûr
des salles de classe 14 ans fille
théâtre et 22 laboratoires
la particularité de cette école c'est
qu'avant de commencer les cours tous les
étudiants font six mois de stage
obligatoire dans le civil où le
militaire et chacun a son anecdote à
raconter
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il s'installe pour de bon
sur le campus des élèves sont tous des
petits génies des mathématiques mais à
polytechnique
ils feront aussi beaucoup de sport alors
dès le premier jour ils sont répartis en
différents groupes en fonction de la
discipline qu'ils ont choisi
alexandra rys au l'entraîneur de boxe et
leur prof principal
[Musique]
vous suivez omaha salles de cours allez
c'est parti je suis une innovation dans
le coffre ils sont une vingtaine comme
axel à avoir choisi la boxe pendant
toute leur scolarité alexandre sera le
référent
mais ici on ne plaisante pas avec les
disciplines tous les chefs de sections
sont des militaires et ça file droit
comme un moyen mels et moins jeunes
chefs se terminer c'est pas biz salut à
la prochaine c'est au revoir les
étudiants sont des élèves officiers et
touche 900 euros par mois tout au long
du cursus qui dure quatre ans l'adjudant
chef alexandre et responsable du groupe
de 25 étudiants c'est leur interlocuteur
privilégié à polytechnique
alors il préfère mettre les choses au
point dès le départ je préfère qu'on me
disiez d'entrée les choses franchement
plus tôt pour me cacher quelque chose
parce qu'à un moment donné je le sais je
préfère que romaine moi je cherche ma
fille parce que j'avais peut-être que ça
va pas me plaire mais au moins il ya
d'accord et j'apprécie ça le langage est
pour le moins direct mais cela n'empêche
pas alexandre d'être galant
c'est le moment des si les tenues pour
la boxe alors l'adjudant s'adresse aussi
aux jeunes femmes du groupe les filles
un bref courrier voir des beaux gosses
c'est bon d'en sortir
les garçons c'est pas compliqué les
celui sans la regarder les tailles des
shorts et on est entre nous donc vous
pouvez vous mettre à poil en général 40
abandonne aussi ce qui veut dire que je
pas dû être
mais quand vous avez tout essayé les
pêcheurs et les shorts vous venez je
vois ce que les chamois vous déposer le
chèque au niveau il a exposé précieux
face à la mer c'est mgi axel va
découvrir sa chambre sous contrat avec
l'armée
il a l'obligation de dormir là du lundi
au vendredi la mère oui donc non une
bévue bon après y'a pas la mer c'est
assez paisible se verront alors a
sagement les la gueule alors bien
d'amitié
ici pas de dortoir chaque étudiant à une
chambre de 20 m² pour toute sa scolarité
sur le campus
tout le monde connaît polytechnique
cette fameuse école qui défilent le 14
juillet
[Musique]
on reconnaît ses étudiants à leur
uniforme leur big horn et leur ep signe
de leur prestige
il ouvre la marche devant les autres
écoles militaires comme saint cyr ou
naval polytechnique
c'est l'une des écoles qui forment
l'élite de la france parmi ses anciens
élèves aux comptes bernard arnault le
numéro un du luxe des prix nobel
d'économie comme jean tirole ou de
physique comme henri becquerel des
maréchaux comme foch et joffre et des
présidents de la république comme valéry
giscard d'estaing pour faire partie du
gratin la sélection est impitoyable
l'an dernier sur 4700 candidats 800
franchissent la barrière des épreuves
écrites et 500 seulement ont été retenus
on les appelle les x à cause de leur
discipline reine
les mathématiques et des deux canons
croisé sur leur blason
alors qui sont ces polytechniciens des
petits génies des jeunes bourré
d'ambition ou tout simplement des hommes
et des femmes bien dans leur tête et
ouvert sur le monde
[Musique]
quand on entre à polytechnique
il y a des moments qu'on n'oublie pas
comme ce rendez-vous à la blanchisserie
axel va recevoir ce qu'on appelle le
grand uniforme de polytechniciens cet
uniforme militaire a très peu évolué
depuis l'époque de napoléon
les maîtres tailleurs jette un dernier
coup d'oeil c'est du sur mesure
qu'est ce que vous regardez là ne peux
je regarde le bien aller voir si
esthétiquement allait bien alors il est
très bien il est parfait il prend
beaucoup les techniciens il fera il il
est déjà trop politique forte et bien
l'uniforme en tout cas
tu penses que des parents très fiers de
voir en mi temps oui je pense qu'ils
seront bien c'est qu'une question de
temps avant qu'ils me chez les filles en
revanche on sent une pointe de déception
la jupe est vraiment des mots des droits
des féminines ce costume
il ne le porteront que pour de grandes
occasions c'est l'habit officiel des
polytechniciens lors des cérémonies une
tradition aussi vieille que l'école il
ne manque plus que le bicorne et l'épée
qu'ils recevront plus tard
mais en attendant comme tous les
étudiants ils prennent plaisir à se
retrouver autour d'un simple barbecue
[Musique]
mais la troisième principale c'est quand
même beaucoup d'amour beaucoup d'intérêt
et on s'amuse aussi
soyez les nouveaux
son désir est quoi les samouraïs axel et
peut-être un petit génie des maths mais
pour la gastronomie il se contente de
junk food pas très appétissante
heureusement pour améliorer l'ordinaire
il ya ce qu'on appelle le barde étage
louise 21 ans étudiante en 2e année
prend la plupart de ces repas ici
entouré de ses amis
à la différence de la cantine
ici les étudiants achète en commun leur
nourriture qualité supérieure
l'ambiance est conviviale et la découvre
à peine des lendemains de fête
difficiles
cela ne les empêche pas de calculer au
gramme près ce que chacun ingurgite
histoire de ne léser personne
louvier c'est une relation je prends des
pattes je fais de la quantité
je vais sur le site internet
démonstration avec les petits légumes
surgelés louise pèse ce qu'elle va
cuisiner puis elle le note sur
l'ordinateur du bar dans un logiciel
inventé par les élèves
ainsi chacun sait combien donner au pot
commun mais les tâches entre filles et
garçons ne sont pas forcément bien
répartis
il ya deux filles il y en a une qui
cuisinent pour ce qu'ils ont fait les
pattes on a essayé plusieurs modèles
je suis rendu compte que celui super
efficace ce sont des princesses en fait
les filles alix c'est une histoire très
récente
c'est seulement en 1972 qu'elles y ont
fait leur entrée
depuis elles sont en moyenne 75 par
promo sur 500 élèves
[Musique]
alix il faut un excellent niveau en
maths physique et chimie en cours de
mécanique à moins d'être un spécialiste
difficile de comprendre de quoi il
s'agit
en fait je n'ai pas réécrit il faut pas
oublier qu'on a des petits donne ce
petit l'homme élastique plus epsilon
plastique epsilon epsilon pour le commun
des mortels ciblé chinois pour louise
pas de problème
c'est limpide on étudiants très très
chaude à l'extérieur c'est zéro degré et
on essaye de faire des simulations pour
voir comment va se déforme as you say
tap pointu mais louise il voit une
application directe au fonctionnement
des fusées et l'aérospatiale c'est sa
passion lancer des satellites et des
fusées dans l'espace passionnés qu'eux
dès le cours terminé
louise va mettre en pratique sa leçon de
mécanique avec les moyens du bord car
ton eau du robinet et bouteilles en
plastique
[Musique]
on est encore loin de la fusée ariane
reste à savoir si louise a bien compris
le principe de la propulsion échec
partiel
c'est un problème de direction assez
flagrant fusée mais louise ne se
décourage pas pour autant
alvaro tenter cette expérience très
scientifique
le compte à rebours est lancé avant les
divisions il y en a beaucoup dans la
tête après souvent pour ce que manu et
leur pendant que certains préfèrent
jouer les dj amateur louise essaie de
faire partager sa passion aux autres
étudiants
[Musique]
cette élection est super le rêve de
louise c'est le tourisme spatial
elle a des étoiles plein les yeux notre
[Applaudissements]
des étudiants qui ont des idées
brillantes il y en a plein les
techniques
david est en dernière année et il est
déjà chef d'entreprise voici son bureau
va m² partager avec ses premiers
employés dans un incubateur de start up
avec un autre élève de l'x david a mis
au point une cote de smartphone
révolutionnaire qui imprime des photos
c'est simple on va prendre on à
l'application
encore moins celle ci après alors j'ai
pris en photo j'ai confirmé que la photo
était bonne et la photo est envoyé à
l'imprimante est mort juste de sortir et
imprimés et on renvoie la faute au
sortir de l'écran et à paraître dans la
réalité surtout david a ajouté une
fonction magique
une fois la photo imprimée le téléphone
la reconnaît et on peut revoir en vidéo
ce qui s'est passé juste avant la prise
de la photo alors qu'on te donne une
photo à un ami on lui donne une vidéo en
même temps
[Musique]
enrc l'idée de cette petite séquence
vidéo c'est justement de pouvoir revivre
le moment à fond et de pouvoir justement
partagé ce moment avec ses amis ses
temples et les premiers pas de son
enfant qu'on va pouvoir partager avec
ses grands parents c'est à dire que je
vais donner la photo physique à ma grand
mère ou à mon grand-père et pourront
rejouer ce moment-là ce moment magique
directement sur la sur la photo et c'est
comme comme s'il était en fait l'idée
lui est venue un peu par hasard en
surfant sur le web
il tombe sur ce projet de coqs
imprimantes mais l'objet n'existe pas
dans le commerce il décide de le
fabriquer à l'époque david et à la fac
de berkeley en californie
43e année polytechnique envoie ses
étudiants à l'étranger
il lance alors une campagne sur un site
de financement participatif américains à
la base on demandé cinquante mille euros
pour pouvoir financer nos outillage fin
pour la production et on a récolté plus
d'un million cinq de dollars de gens qui
ont cru en notre projet et qui ont pré
acheté pré commander le produit avant
qu'une sorte donc encore un signe de
l'engouement du public dans quelques
jours david présentera son invention
dans un concours de jeunes entrepreneurs
[Musique]
la vie à polytechnique ses 25 heures de
cours par semaine dont 6 de sport
obligatoire
axel a choisi la boxe pour son chef de
section l'adjudant alexandre c'est un
bon moyen de le préparer à sa vie future
a cette confiance en soi qu'il aura
gagné sur un sport de contact mais lui
permettra de s'exprimer plus facilement
vis-à-vis des hommes publics ou
injustement dans d'autres personnels sur
l'entreprise et donc comme hier on va
travailler sur sidaction partenaire mon
partenaire se déplace au bras le long du
corps quand il s'arrête
il me présente les cibles comme les
oreilles de mickey en joie
[Musique]
oui
mais pas portail
3 2 les 25 élèves n'en sont qu'au
deuxième cours de boxe et non pas encore
des physiques d'athlètes l'apprentissage
de la boxe est une oeuvre de longue
haleine l'entraîneur prend soin de tout
expliquer car bien un jour devant
l'autre ok
au poisson
dans la recherche de vitesse qui est
quand même vachement important en boxe
en revanche pour certains c'est encore
un peu tôt comme vous allez vite il ya
des défauts qui apparaissent
[Musique]
le chef de section fait un suivi
personnalisé de ses couleurs mais axel
at il bien compris le but pédagogique de
l'exercice c'est un sport d'opposition
en effet rencontre quelqu'un on en sait
a dit aussi au début que la boxe ça
pouvait permettre je crois que c'est le
premier jour qui nous on dit ça on la
boxe ça pouvait avoir les avantages de
mieux gérer les duels en fait pas
forcément points mais greg d'être face à
quelqu'un et de pas dû réagir à se faire
déstabiliser
axel fait six heures de boxe par semaine
mais rien n'empêche les élèves d'en
faire beaucoup plus
[Musique]
allez on tend les mains on appelle à
copé louise a choisi le rugby à
polytechnique le sport est inscrit dans
l'adn de l'école et que c'est de là que
ça vient fait convoyer autant le sport
[Musique]
militaire et en même temps c'est son dit
partout que corps sans expression louise
pour le rugby très au sérieux et sur le
terrain elles montrent déjà des qualités
de capitaine d'équipé
pas de doute c'est un futur leader
[Musique]
c'est comme la physique un mois je me
serais donc je fais c'est ce que j'aime
dans mon rugby c'est que c'est un sport
qui a l'air un sport de brutes
à première vue mais en fait il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de techniques et et
particulièrement vers 7 6 a pas
tellement de contacter a vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de courses de passer
ou en gagner sur sur la stratégie plus
que sur sur le jeu les moules et les
mots du poète
allez on fait deux colonnes devant moi
lier à l'attack d'ailleurs à la défense
allez go tout n'affiche pas la même
assurance sur le terrain il y a encore
des progrès à faire
du coup l'équipe n'est pas très au point
mais les résultats sont encourageants
[Musique]
c'est la seule activité des filles ou
les garçons restent sur la touche et ses
demoiselles n'y voit que des avantages
de section des sports individuels ou cd
sport même en basket on a une équipe
féminine on s'entraîne toujours avec les
garçons et j'en oublie féminin c'est
l'occasion de se retrouver juste entre
filles de se retrouver aussi avec les
filles qui sont pas dans notre section
qu'on n'a pas toujours l'habitude de
voir et du coup c'est ça qui est c'est
sympa quoi sympa de se retrouver entre
filles aussi parce que on n'a jamais
cette occasion là en dehors et du coup
faire un sport entre filles comme ça en
plus un sport réputé de mecs et se
défouler comme ça ça c'est génial faut
faire du rugby
sain de corps et d'esprit cela ne suffit
pas à polytechnique
certains cours ont de quoi surprendre
une fois par mois les politiciens ont le
droit de boire en classe c'est légal et
c'est même encouragé un professeur
d'oenologie est venue de la fac de
bordeaux leur enseigner les bases de la
dégustation
on va essayer de faire un petit tour de
france des grandes régions productrices
de façon en même temps avoir la
géographie dietikon voilà alors on va
commencer tout commence par le raisin
pour faire du vin axel s'est inscrit à
cette dégustation pour découvrir un
univers qu'il ne connaît pas du tout
qu'on connaît pas on n'ose pas acheter
sais pas quoi acheter jamais dans
l'élite française ignorer les bons vins
c'est une faute de goût et je pense que
ce sont des personnes qui sont amenés à
avoir des postes de responsabilité très
importante dans le futur et une vie
sociale très importante la france la vie
sociale savs avec les repas d'affaires
elven la connaissance qui font partie
intégrante de cette ville pour capter
l'attention de ces scientifiques le prof
a la bonne idée de parler leur langage
ce qui va se développer c'est le plan
normatif
mais c'est donc cette estérification
dont je parlais qui est la
transformation de l'alcool éthylique ans
en ester et visiblement ça fonctionne je
pensais pas qu'il y aura des réactions
mais je pense qu'il a fait des maths
[Musique]
au menu du jour un côtes-du-rhône un
riesling alsacien est un vin d'anjou
quand on met en bouche on recrée la même
sensation que celle qu'on a sonné c'est
à dire qu'on veut créer une oxydation
donc on va laisser rentrer et de l'air
en même temps qu'on le met en bouche
je prends mon frère là j'ai créé cette
sensation aromatiques pour la voir en
bouche et pas sonné
je m'attendais un peu plus fort fait
dans le sens
un jour les élèves sont peut être amené
à s'asseoir à la table des grands chefs
d'entreprise
comme le numéro un du luxe à la tête de
dior ou vuitton
le patron du groupe lvmh bernard arnault
ancien polytechnicien de la promotion
1969 c'est une école dirait un peu multi
culturel où on a la chance pendant les
études d'approcher des camarades qui ont
des perspectives extrêmement différentes
les unes des autres et donc d'être en
contact avec un bouillonnement
intellectuel comme rarement on en a
l'occasion pendant sa vie
professionnelle dans les métiers du luxe
quand un ancien élève de l'école réussi
c'est qu'ils arrivent à combiner ces
deux aspects de la personnalité
la logique l'esprit cartésien cher aux
mathématiciens et la créativité
l'inventivité et la combinaison des deux
assez rare en fait donne des résultats
très spectaculaire souvent fin mai pour
le 150e anniversaire du bal de
polytechnique l'école a vu les choses en
grand
elle a privatisé un lieu exceptionnel le
château de versailles avec des invités
triés sur le volet
[Musique]
cette année bernard arnault est le
président du bal il va accueillir les
vip accompagné de son épouse et des
tambours de la garde républicaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un cadre prestigieux pour une école
bicentenaire au rayonnement
international
avant le dîner les invités ont rendez
vous dans un lieu unique du château
l'opéra royal pour l'ouverture les
organisateurs ont invité le chinois lang
lang un des meilleurs pianistes au monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci avant de quitter l'opéra
bernard arnault pause pour la
traditionnelle photo avec les élèves de
l'x parmi eux il ya son troisième fils
qui vient de réussir le concours
d'entrée
bernard arnault va profiter de la soirée
pour faire passer un message
contrairement aux idées reçues
polytechnique est ouverte à tous
c'est l'école du mérite c'est quand même
unique comme image et comme image de la
france et unique également d'avoir une
école de si haut niveau qui sont
ouvertes a autant d'étudiants différent
parce que on est toujours c'est l'élite
et c est en fait c'est pas vrai les
élèves qui sont
polytechnicien sont sans doute l'élite
intellectuelle en matière scientifique
mais quand ils sont choisis dans
l'ensemble de la nation et ils viennent
de tous horizons et de tous milieux et
c'est valable aujourd'hui c'était
valable à mon époque
c'est le cas de la famille de david le
jeune inventeur de la coque imprimantes
ses parents ne sont ni politique ni sien
ni grands patrons au départ rien ne
prédisposait la famille tang à rejoindre
l'élite des écoles françaises les
parents de david chang et ya ping pong
vivait confortablement en chine une vie
rythmée par les études elle en pharmacie
lui en mécanique
sur le chemin les photos quand même
raconté un peu leur vie avant et quand
ils ont travaillé dur pour que je sens
mon frère et moi on est notre vie
aujourd'hui en france mais on est assez
privilégiés par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
eu avant
photo agricole c'est la photo je vais
manquer de pharmacie dans les années 80
ils viennent en france pour compléter
leur diplôme
quand bien suivre quand c'est venu en
france c'est un champion et non parce
que liga entre le chine dans les années
80 et la france sinon les filles en sont
là ça me donne encore plus envie plus
envie de
travailler dur mais en 1989 sur la place
tiananmen
les chars du régime écrase des étudiants
qui manifestent sous le choc
le couple tangue reste en france david
né un an plus tard c'est leur deuxième
fils en chine
il était interdit d'avoir plus d'un
enfant le petit david montre assez vite
un intérêt pour la technologie et chez
les dogues
on connaît la valeur du travail et de la
réussite
david a toujours été poussé par ses
parents les deux petites banques
deviennent des bêtes de concours
l'aîné ici à droite entre hc david
réussit plis techniques
une fierté pour ses parents qui
assisteront dans quelques jours à la
remise de son diplôme
à six semaines du défilé du 14 juillet
les premières années sont convoqués dans
la cour d'honneur
ils vont répéter pour leur premier
défilé
maniez ctp que l'on appelle tangente
dans le jargon de polytechnique demande
une précision millimétrée votre index
recouvre toute la partie arrondi de la
tangente comme ceux ci allaient votre
main droite
on va passer au moment de porter arms 2
3 ramène un deux trois c'est pas mal
c'est bien même présenté 2 3 le repos
c'est un ordre donc il faut que je sois
simultanée au même titre que le garde à
vous axel essaie de faire bonne figure
mais il ne semble pas avoir complètement
intégré l'esprit militaire de la maison
avant de rentrer dans l'école j'avais
jamais vu ce que c'était enfin
garde-à-vous peut-être dans les films
comme ça au passage que j'avais jamais
vraiment fait attention à l'épreuve les
premières fois c'est étonnant 11e 12e
reçoit des ordres comme ça
la hauteur c'est une fierté énorme de
les voir le jour du 14 juillet parce que
c'est un plaisir
c'est un plaisir c'est trop de plaisir
le descendre les champs elysées on lundi
que jamais la descente se termine et
puis c'est une grande fierté pour eux
pour nous pour la famille pour pour la
cadre d'un militaire et pour l'école de
défiler ce jour là quoi dans dix jours
les étudiants se retrouveront tous en
uniforme pour la traditionnelle
passation de drapeaux devant le ministre
de la défense pendant ce temps là c'est
le grand jour pour david il est l'invité
d'une émission qui met en concurrence
des start up
nous sommes au stade des quarts de
finale et c'est le seul étudiant en lice
le vainqueur de la finale gagnera des
spots de publicité david à deux
concurrents face à lui le créateur d'un
site de mode masculine est l'inventeur
d'un robot aspirateur debout on passe à
votre candidat suivant
il s'appelle david wang il est venu nous
présenter prédit cette année on va
produire 20000 dans fait maintenant
c'est trente mille unités et
prochainement à produire 200 mille
unités
comment vous pouvez me raconter ça avec
un ton aussi placide est la plus beaux
fleurons eu dix fois plus que prévu
non celle de dengue êtes en prévente un
peu comme les primeurs dans le pinard et
vous lui dites qu'à 80 mille euros par
mois de commandes représente du produit
qui n'est pas encore livrés ouais et
voulurent et quand on livre en octobre
bon 140 euros la cox ça c'est ça à la
base on avec mon associé clément qu'on a
commencé cette aventure qu'est ce qu'on
s'est dit c'est le jour on sera vraiment
fiers de nous ces jours on aura 25
personnes qui travaillent avec nous des
beaux bureaux et que les gens soient
contents portrait de travailler dans
cette entreprise
c'est le moment de retenir un seul
candidat
le choix du coach l'aventuré américaine
me transporte donc je choisis print
parce que j'ai envie de faire mes
valises et partir à san francisco à les
mouches
david a gagné il accède aux demi finales
ils vous racontent des croissances
exponentielles le crs de las vegas où il
a été une vedette
cette levée de fonds sur kickstarter oui
il faut cinq ans pile bull il en a un
million et demi en 30 jours et vous dis
ça avec une platitude de tranquillité
totale
le zéro stress absolu lui quand on lui
demandait s'il s'était préparé cette
émission one la clairière près pareil du
tout qu'il y en a pas besoin
façon c'est son bébé c'est son histoire
il a tout inventé ils ont fabriqué ce ma
vie ce merveilleux produits
technologiques et on sent que voilà le
l'autoroute est ouverte et tout va très
bien se passer et quand david gagne
polytechnique gagne aussi 5 juin dernier
les élèves ont revêtu l'uniforme des
grandes occasions
ils vont recevoir le drapeau de l'école
en présence du ministre de la défense
vous avez bien accrochez votre ceinture
qu'elle fasse pas recevoir le drapeau
c'est marqué son entrée définitive dans
le cercle des polytechniciens
vous allez voir la cérémonie la mise à
place ça va assez vite ensuite les
arrivées du chef de corps présentation
aux troupes
le ministre de la défense a ceremony va
la civic comme je vous l'aï dit ça va
glisser l'uniforme a beau être célèbre
il n'est pas très commode
être au mieux la nourrice toi qui donne
le top à tokyo 5 6
dans la foule les parents d'élèves
découvre pour la première fois leurs
enfants en uniforme parmi eux il y à
bernard arnault dont le fils vient de
réussir le concours
quand le ministre de la défense jean
yves le drian arrive tout est en place
pour la revue des troupes
[Musique]
les techniciens des pluies
d'électriciens de la combustion de ce
drapeau que les deuxièmes années confie
aux premières années c'est l'attachement
d'une école bicentenaire aux valeurs de
la france le drapeau a même reçu la
légion d'honneur en hommage aux
polytechniciens tombés pour la patrie
les nouveaux entonnent le chant de la 2e
division blindée du maréchal leclerc
après le chemin qui mène vers paris ils
ont de gros espoirs merveilleux
deux bataillons de dans le régiment aimé
vivre la 2e db
[Applaudissements]
à la fin de la cérémonie axel cherche
ses parents dans la foule
c'est la première fois que les parents
des premières années voient leurs
enfants défilé et ils ne sont pas peu
fiers
ça vous a fait quoi de le voir les idées
aujourd'hui c'était une grande émotion
est impossible ce jour là monsieur et
madame arnaud sont comme tous les
parents bernard arnault immortalisent le
moment avec son téléphone
je trouve magnifique et très très touché
par les impressionner par cette
cérémonie aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ça
représente l'excellence et avec toutes
ces traditions tradition le jeune homme
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti à ce
défilé là c'était fallait fallait être
concentré fallait essayer de ne pas
faire de faux pas c'est ça oui oui
surtout si en plus on était jugé pour le
défilé du 14 juillet au moins ne faut
pas ont été éliminés par le 14 juillet
donc on était survoltées bourse est bon
pour le 14 juillet vanseveren bon super
bowl a donc rendez vous au prochain
défilé du 14 juillet formidable
axel enfin retrouver ses parents
accompagné de son meilleur ami
je suis très fier faut pas le cacher
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti en
voyant qu'on voulait qu'on voulait vu la
première phase est la première fois oui
oui oui
et du coup ça m'a fait plaisir
je suis très fier après quatre ans
d'études
axel espère devenir chercheur en
physique
quelques jours après le défilé des
nouveaux polytechnicien ceux qui
terminent leur quatrième année se
préparent au grand jour de la remise des
diplômes et ce jour là on se croirait
presque au lancement d'une fusée
premier en toge ce sont les professeurs
polytechnique veut se montrer l'égal des
plus grandes écoles au monde et ça
ressemble un peu à un show à
l'américaine
des plats aux intervenants que je suis
d'ouvrir la cérémonie de remise des
diplômes 2010 sur scène profs élèves
vont se succéder les stars des maths
sont devenus des adultes prêts à
s'assumer en public après avoir fait la
robotique au collège et d'informatique
en prépa j'ai toujours été plus à l'aise
avec les ordinateurs qu'avec les gens le
court qui m'a le plus marqué ici
fondement de l'informatique se focaliser
sur les capacités et les limites des
ordinateurs je me suis d'ailleurs
secours soulignent surtout les capacités
et limites des élèves
on n'y comprenait parfois pas grand
chose tout en haut de l'amphi monsieur
et madame zinc sont bien là les
étudiants défilent un parent et david
reçoit enfin son diplôme une ligne de
plus sur le cv
et pas n'importe laquelle
alors david ce diplôme
/
david est clément les deux fondateurs de
la start up sont déjà tournés vers
l'avenir
ça représente peut-être plus pour nos
parents que pour nous après on fait on
fait l'entrepreneuriat c'est je pense la
matière dans laquelle l'école dont vient
à le moins d'importance au monde donc
non mais après c'est toujours gratifiant
de se dire que parler on allait
polytechnique on a fini polytechnique
et voilà mais après c'est pas ça qui va
faire notre carrière et qui a frappé ses
parents sont presque plus impressionné
que le nouveau diplômé
[Musique]
j'ai senti la fierté et surtout je me
suis dit ils sont ils seulement non
seulement pour david pour l'ensemble des
élèves
ils sont jeunes ils sont brillants ils
sont
et c'était des efforts et je crois que
c'est la france
mais si j'étais pas non parce que je
sais que ça ça le rend heureux et ils
sont fiers de mon parfois j'ai fait
plaisir david fait partie des 2 % de
polytechniciens qui montrent leur
entreprise après l'école les autres
deviennent ingénieur financier aux
fonctionnaires et très rarement
militaire